week-in week-out rife Badar wheeze
supporters call for his release in front
of the Saudi Arabian embassy in Berlin
this Friday his wife ends up hide our is
also present she's very grateful for all
the support Alison shot that level thank
you I know that it's not enough but all
I can say is thank you I thank each and
every one of you Nash would come watch
I'd laugh at what she is hopeful that
the campaign would eventually have a
positive impact on the Saudi authorities
ll and these demonstrations have already
raised a lot of support for me and drive
and given us a lot of strength dammit
namana we and now I have a feeling that
the whole world is behind us SNL alum
coolio Mariah at Menominee I would like
this to continue until rife is set free
hella become mana Elena hi a llamar a
fertile area to Amnesty International
has gathered thousands of signatures in
support of right Badawi but they want
the German government to apply pressure
on Riyadh dots understand Vista go to
Germany is an important economic partner
and we've talked about this with the
government as well as the business
community which has dealings with Saudi
Arabia over and over again I think now's
the right time to keep at it statistical
point and whiter than sublime supporters
are calling for a journalism award to be
created in bahamas name so that his
voice isn't silenced while he is in
prison